for the first time in eight years the
u.s navy's fifth fleet
publicly announced that it moved a
guided missile submarine into the
persian gulf
this comes one day after the american
embassy in baghdad was attacked
by a barrage of rockets that was said to
have caused minor damage
and one death the uss georgia guided
missile submarine armed with 154
tomahawk cruise missiles
has transited the strait of hormuz and
entered the persian gulf
let's get details on sunday's attack in
baghdad correspondent trey yanks reports
tonight from our middle east newsroom
the u.s embassy's air defense system
fires interception rounds into the sky
over baghdad its target eight katusha
rockets aimed at the green zone
inside the iraqi capital diplomatic
sources told reuters at least one
civilian was killed
and minor damage was done to the embassy
compound
the event drew condemnation from the
iraqi government that called this a
terrorist attack
as u.s secretary of state mike pompeo
blamed iranian-backed militias tweeting
quote
these violent and corrupt criminals must
cease their destabilizing actions
the statement drew a direct response
from iran's foreign ministry
and recall i think that the iraqi
government will definitely find the
perpetrators
and those who order it based on its
duties i
also want the united states regime not
to seek starting a fire
and wage in conflict these days the
american embassy
was the target of numerous rocket
attacks over the past year
conducted by suspected iranian-backed
shia militias
though sunday's rocket fire comes just
two weeks before the one-year
anniversary
of a u.s drone strike that killed top
iranian general qasim solamani
in baghdad the killing led iran to fire
ballistic missiles
at a military base housing american
troops in iraq
last january this january the trump
administration will reduce the number of
u.s forces
operating in the country from 3 000 to
2500 soldiers
calculations are ongoing for iran and
its proxies across the middle east
there is hope by the regime in tehran
that a biden administration could lift
economic sanctions on the islamic
republic while allowing them to continue
a controlled nuclear program
brett trey hanks in our middle east
newsroom trey thank you